so we're taking questions a lot of you
are facing some fear out there you're
afraid of the economy the harm to the
economy brought on by what is perceived
to be the cure
not the cure but the way to limit the
pandemic is everyone stay at home and
shut down all the businesses which shuts
down people's income which shuts down
their lives and so their lives are being
harmed more by the Cure the average
person in America then by the actual
virus and and some of you are very very
afraid we've been urging people to
remain calm no one makes good decisions
when they're drunk or when they're
panicked and some of you are both and
you some of you're being really mean to
other people because you're afraid and
you need to check yourself this is a
time that you need to grow up or the
garden if you're 54 and and you know I
think one of the things I've seen that
has caused people to be the meanest
particularly when it's directed at
public figures including myself is when
I don't know what this is John in the
human psyche you can help me with this I
there's a level of arrogance mmm
aristocracy right since entitlement
sense that tells you that it's not only
your job to manage your space but you're
supposed to tell everyone else what
today hmm so we've stood winners kids we
say nunya right none your business all
right but mind your own business but
people can't do that anymore they're
really good at minding everyone else's
business but you got a full-time job is
taking care of your house right now you
no more than a full-time job you get
more than a full-time job taking care of
your own head right now I think we
talked about fierce causing people to be
unkind I also think insecurity is -
because there's this myth that we all
should know what we're supposed to do
all the time especially husbands and
dads across the country moms and wives
across the country I'm supposed to know
what to do
at this moment I don't know what to do
and then the best way I can solve that
sometimes it's to yell at somebody else
and tell them Alton you're doing yours
wrong right like we have this hierarchy
if as long as I'm not as bad as my
neighbor is that I'm okay yeah and that
goes directly in opposition to just
being kind my critical thinking path
that I don't know where it came from it
may be just my hillbilly rebellion self
but um its contrarian and so as soon as
someone says this is the way it is I
immediately think oh it's not that's
exactly how I am - that's right no it's
not it's like and you know the CDC says
this and I'm like my cousin works at the
CDC you know that proves it right there
you know I mean it's like so what if
what if we're in the new rebellion is
kindness yeah or the new rebellion is
tipping obnoxiously right yeah or
delivering groceries to somebody shut in
that's right as you said you'd walk down
the street with a garbage bag in rubber
gloves with your son picking up trash
just to get out the house get some
vitamin D but that's exactly you know
that's right and how's that for a new
rebellion right yeah a whole different
kind of a communist rebellion but I'm
just my point is is that my first
inclination is to be a sheepdog as to
the Sheep mm-hmm
I immediately challenge authority
whatever it is and you know you know my
wife is pregnant with our first child 35
years ago in the obese is such a section
I went I don't think so
oh man and she said you're not bad about
that not a doctor I said yeah I know but
you're gonna have to prove that I did
not just take it just because you got a
white coat and a stethoscope does not
mean I'm gonna believe you you got to
make your case dude hmm and you know I
made this case and I went along but you
know but it's not it was not you know
I'm not gonna just automatically fall in
line that's right that's my nature and
so just because the president says
something the governor says something
for God's sakes the mayor says something
that's proof right there that I'm just
not going along you know I'm not
necessarily gonna think the way they
think I have other responsibilities I
have critical thinking skills that are
different and I have you know I have to
think for myself and you gotta think for
yourself that's right in this and so you
know I've got a friend who's recovering
from cancer and has been through chemo
and he's thinking
for himself which he's staying at home
it's a really good idea yeah that's
right yeah and not being you know out
there not connecting to anybody because
he's in a weakened state he's in a
high-risk category with this thing so
answering your questions about those
subjects about fear anxiety about money
about life on the planet right now in
this weird and wacky time we love you
but we love ourselves to the point
you're not allowed to be mean and so I'm
not gonna fight with you you're just
wrong you need to be kind say just need
to calm your little butt down and be
kind